Speaker 1: the context for these talks that I give are
Speaker 1: always the same.
Speaker 1: It's always about how to introduce people
Speaker 1: to a completely different dimension of
Speaker 1: reality, to introduce everybody to the
Speaker 1: nature of enlightenment, the nature of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: So I'm speaking in a particular context, to
Speaker 1: illuminate a particular dimension of
Speaker 1: reality, and I'm just offering one
Speaker 1: perspective and one maybe helpful way to
Speaker 1: think about something that's very difficult
Speaker 1: to understand.
Speaker 1: As Ken Wilber reminds us, he often says
Speaker 1: that the map is not the territory.
Speaker 1: So in this talk, I'm going to try to give
Speaker 1: you a simple and fairly easy to understand
Speaker 1: way to think about who you are, so you can
Speaker 1: navigate between these different dimensions
Speaker 1: of yourself throughout the day and
Speaker 1: hopefully learn how to make the right
Speaker 1: choices.
Speaker 1: Because when we're occupying parts of
Speaker 1: ourselves that aren't our best friends,
Speaker 1: it's often it's often a good time maybe not
Speaker 1: to talk and not to make any important life
Speaker 1: decisions.
Speaker 1: That's kind of the idea.
Speaker 1: But uh, two weeks ago, one of my students
Speaker 1: asked me a question in this forum, in this
Speaker 1: context, and he said when I was talking
Speaker 1: about making choices, and he, and he asked
Speaker 1: me the question who this forum in this
Speaker 1: context?
Speaker 1: And he said when I was talking about making
Speaker 1: choices and he asked me the question who's
Speaker 1: the one that's making the choices, who's
Speaker 1: the chooser?
Speaker 1: So it's in response to his question that
Speaker 1: I'm giving this talk tonight, or where I am
Speaker 1: this evening, about who the chooser is and
Speaker 1: I want to give you a brief tour of the
Speaker 1: nature of what I'm going to call the four
Speaker 1: selves.
Speaker 1: So hopefully in a way that will enable you
Speaker 1: to find these four selves inside your own
Speaker 1: self and hopefully enable you to make to
Speaker 1: choose the self of the selves that you'd
Speaker 1: like to be choosing and not to be
Speaker 1: victimized unconsciously by parts of
Speaker 1: yourself that you're not even aware of or
Speaker 1: don't even understand.
Speaker 1: But once again, we're going to talk about
Speaker 1: the self and ego, structures and things
Speaker 1: like that, and there's so many ways we can
Speaker 1: talk about the human condition.
Speaker 1: It's so complex.
Speaker 1: So the model that I'm going to be using in
Speaker 1: this talk is very simple.
Speaker 1: It excludes so much of who we are, because
Speaker 1: I'm not trying to give a comprehensive,
Speaker 1: multidimensional picture or map of all the
Speaker 1: dimensions of being human.
Speaker 1: I'm very specifically interested in
Speaker 1: conveying the kind of information that I
Speaker 1: have found is necessary and important.
Speaker 1: That would enable us to make the right
Speaker 1: choices if our heart and our soul is
Speaker 1: focused on actualizing our potential for
Speaker 1: waking into enlightened awareness or to
Speaker 1: become enlightened.
Speaker 1: So.
Speaker 1: So the way I'm going to be speaking about
Speaker 1: the four cells is specifically designed
Speaker 1: with that in mind.
Speaker 1: So what I'm going to do, I'm going to do.
Speaker 1: The definitions I'm giving you are not very
Speaker 1: complex, they're very simplistic, they're
Speaker 1: very easy to understand and they leave a
Speaker 1: lot out of the picture.
Speaker 1: But just to repeat, I'm leaving a lot out
Speaker 1: of the picture because I'm only interested
Speaker 1: in these talks and helping to convey one
Speaker 1: thing, which is how to see ourselves and
Speaker 1: how to relate to the human experience we're
Speaker 1: having if our heart's intention is to be
Speaker 1: spiritually liberated and to awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: I'm not going to be speaking very much
Speaker 1: about the unconscious self, unconscious
Speaker 1: motivations, shadow and that kind of thing,
Speaker 1: because for the point I'm trying to make, I
Speaker 1: don't think it's necessary or important or
Speaker 1: necessarily even part of the journey.
Speaker 1: Very good, so.
Speaker 1: So a big part of the quest for
Speaker 1: enlightenment and awakening to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, a big part of that quest to
Speaker 1: speak in terms most of you have heard
Speaker 1: before is to find out who we are.
Speaker 1: It's the search for the true self.
Speaker 1: And if we pay attention, if, through our
Speaker 1: spiritual practice, we pay attention to the
Speaker 1: experience of being a self that we're
Speaker 1: having from one moment to another, we'll
Speaker 1: find that the self-feeling that we
Speaker 1: experience from one moment to another tends
Speaker 1: to change for various reasons, in different
Speaker 1: circumstances and as a result of different
Speaker 1: kinds of stimulation tends to change for
Speaker 1: various reasons, in different circumstances
Speaker 1: and, as results, different kinds of
Speaker 1: stimulation.
Speaker 1: So I think if we wanna become a conscious
Speaker 1: person which is a big part of what this is
Speaker 1: all about we're aspiring to become a
Speaker 1: conscious person then it's important that
Speaker 1: we know who we are and which part of
Speaker 1: ourselves that we are relating to the world
Speaker 1: from in any given moment.
Speaker 1: Do you know which part of your own self you
Speaker 1: are relating to and identified with at this
Speaker 1: moment?
Speaker 1: Now, one of the things that I've noticed,
Speaker 1: which is very interesting, very simple, but
Speaker 1: very interesting and very revealing and
Speaker 1: very helpful, is that different parts of
Speaker 1: our own self feel have unique kinds of
Speaker 1: emotional traits.
Speaker 1: So what do I mean by that?
Speaker 1: So I mean that the ego, which you have all
Speaker 1: heard about, probably far too much.
Speaker 1: The ego feels like something particular,
Speaker 1: something specific.
Speaker 1: The ego feels like a particular kind of
Speaker 1: experience.
Speaker 1: The ego can feel really good once in a
Speaker 1: while.
Speaker 1: Or the ego can feel really bad and
Speaker 1: absolutely terrible at other times, as I'm
Speaker 1: sure you all already know.
Speaker 1: So the ego and the way I want to speak
Speaker 1: about it today is not a singular
Speaker 1: proposition or a singular event or a
Speaker 1: singular kind of emotional and
Speaker 1: psychological and metaphysical experience.
Speaker 1: What the ego is changes from moment to
Speaker 1: moment and feels differently from moment to
Speaker 1: moment.
Speaker 1: So what am I talking about?
Speaker 1: So the ego is the.
Speaker 1: There's many ways we can speak about the
Speaker 1: ego, but the reason why, if we're speaking
Speaker 1: about enlightenment, we have to speak about
Speaker 1: the ego, because if we are speaking about
Speaker 1: enlightenment by any other, if we sorry if
Speaker 1: we are speaking about enlightenment, then
Speaker 1: enlightenment is always about transcending
Speaker 1: the small self, transcending the ego.
Speaker 1: So, because enlightenment is about
Speaker 1: transcending the ego and that's what this
Speaker 1: talk is all about we have to define our
Speaker 1: terms.
Speaker 1: So the ego, which is not your true self,
Speaker 1: which is usually referred to as a separate
Speaker 1: self, your true self, which is usually
Speaker 1: referred to as a separate self, the ego we
Speaker 1: could call the self-organizing principle in
Speaker 1: the psyche.
Speaker 1: And since we're defining ego in this moment
Speaker 1: as a self-organizing principle in the
Speaker 1: psyche, I think we would all agree that we
Speaker 1: would want our ego to be in good working
Speaker 1: order, to be healthy, to have a healthy ego,
Speaker 1: because if our ego is healthy and in good
Speaker 1: shape which is kind of unusual, but if the
Speaker 1: ego is healthy and in good shape, that
Speaker 1: means the self-organizing principle in the
Speaker 1: psyche, which creates a sense of coherence
Speaker 1: in the self, will be in good shape and that
Speaker 1: means we'll be mentally healthy, which is
Speaker 1: something that we all hope we can attain.
Speaker 1: Mental health it's getting more and more
Speaker 1: difficult these days, I know.
Speaker 1: So.
Speaker 1: The ego is the self-organizing principle in
Speaker 1: the psyche and the ego is the part of the
Speaker 1: self in which we feel our unique
Speaker 1: personality.
Speaker 1: Our unique persona coalesces and exists.
Speaker 1: It feels like to my ego.
Speaker 1: It feels very unique.
Speaker 1: I have a unique persona called Andrew Cohen,
Speaker 1: and that person's had a particular life
Speaker 1: story, life history which makes up a
Speaker 1: historical narrative that his ego
Speaker 1: identifies with.
Speaker 1: His history devise with is his story and my
Speaker 1: persona.
Speaker 1: My ego as a persona is having a certain
Speaker 1: life experience that existed once again in
Speaker 1: a particular now, as part of a particular
Speaker 1: narrative which is unique to me and most of
Speaker 1: us relate to the experience of body-mind,
Speaker 1: time-space through the narrative of this
Speaker 1: egoic persona and, generally speaking, the
Speaker 1: experience of the ego persona tends to be
Speaker 1: less than ecstatic, but it's possible for
Speaker 1: the ego to be in good working order,
Speaker 1: well-functioning, it's possible, that it
Speaker 1: can be healthy.
Speaker 1: Having a healthy ego means that we feel
Speaker 1: good about ourselves, we have a healthy
Speaker 1: self-respect, we respect ourselves, we
Speaker 1: believe that we're good, decent, moral
Speaker 1: beings, we're worthy of love and affection
Speaker 1: and kindness.
Speaker 1: And people who have strong egos, in the
Speaker 1: most positive sense of what it means to
Speaker 1: have a strong ego, tend to be accomplished
Speaker 1: men and women in different ways.
Speaker 1: So as part of this description, I'm trying
Speaker 1: to describe what I would say is a healthy
Speaker 1: ego.
Speaker 1: Part of this description is I'm trying to
Speaker 1: describe what I would say is a healthy ego.
Speaker 1: And if your ego is in good shape, it means
Speaker 1: that you are, that you have.
Speaker 1: If you've endured heavy and intense
Speaker 1: traumatic events in your life, you have not
Speaker 1: been destroyed by them, your soul hasn't
Speaker 1: been destroyed by them and you have.
Speaker 1: Either you've either survived or you've
Speaker 1: recovered.
Speaker 1: So enlightenment, and we wanna awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: The ego's not necessarily a problem, but if
Speaker 1: our ego is unhappy, if our ego is unhappy,
Speaker 1: if our ego has been traumatized, brutalized,
Speaker 1: damaged, traumatized in a very profound way
Speaker 1: and it's not recovered, then that part of
Speaker 1: the self, the small self, the ego, will be
Speaker 1: pregnant with conscious and unconscious
Speaker 1: angers, anger, fear, resentment, pregnant
Speaker 1: with conscious and unconscious angers,
Speaker 1: anger, fear, resentment, existential
Speaker 1: confusion, fear, anxiety and things like
Speaker 1: that.
Speaker 1: We tend to make life, the experience of
Speaker 1: life and conscious life very torturous and
Speaker 1: unpleasant, difficult to navigate and to
Speaker 1: negotiate.
Speaker 1: And the unhappy ego, which has not
Speaker 1: recovered from its traumas and from its bad
Speaker 1: experiences, experiences quite a lot of
Speaker 1: insecurity, fear and doubt.
Speaker 1: Quite a lot of insecurity, fear and doubt.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry, there is an arm.
Speaker 1: I see your camera on my upper left screen.
Speaker 1: It's going in and out and I find it
Speaker 1: distracting a little bit.
Speaker 1: If you could please adjust it so it remains
Speaker 1: in one position.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: So the net, so what I'm describing now is
Speaker 1: the traumatized ego which is not recovered
Speaker 1: from trauma, and it tends to be where many
Speaker 1: of our problems come from.
Speaker 1: The source or origin of a lot of our
Speaker 1: problems that we create for ourselves is
Speaker 1: often the reason that we tend to make bad
Speaker 1: choices.
Speaker 1: It's a place where we feel experience, fear,
Speaker 1: doubt, depression, anxiety, frustration,
Speaker 1: anger, resentment and all these things.
Speaker 1: So the negative ego is a drag.
Speaker 1: The negative ego is the worst part of me,
Speaker 1: is the worst part of each and every one of
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: So in this way, I'd like you to be able to
Speaker 1: see that the ego is both our best friend
Speaker 1: and our worst enemy.
Speaker 1: Now, the negative ego, because it's had
Speaker 1: such a hard time and has not yet recovered
Speaker 1: from that hard time, tends to have all
Speaker 1: kinds of egoic problems, like with
Speaker 1: narcissism and self-identity.
Speaker 1: So the negative ego, the narcissistic ego,
Speaker 1: tends to need to always find a way to see
Speaker 1: itself as being better than and superior to
Speaker 1: the others.
Speaker 1: So the negative ego, the narcissistic ego,
Speaker 1: is often comparing itself to other people
Speaker 1: and is always interpreting its experience
Speaker 1: through this conscious or unconscious will
Speaker 1: or wish to be superior to and better than
Speaker 1: the other or the others.
Speaker 1: And if you ever spend time with a person
Speaker 1: who always feels that they need to find a
Speaker 1: way to feel better than you are, it can
Speaker 1: make you feel uncomfortable.
Speaker 1: For obvious reasons and this is the part of
Speaker 1: the ego that we're seeking for
Speaker 1: enlightenment, or the awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness we have to learn how
Speaker 1: to purify ourselves from it, liberate
Speaker 1: ourselves from it, make ourselves so
Speaker 1: conscious of this unpleasant aspiration for
Speaker 1: superiority, because it's, it's very
Speaker 1: destructive for our spiritual aspirations.
Speaker 1: So this is a big subject.
Speaker 1: So now we're speaking about the ego as
Speaker 1: being positive, our best friend and our
Speaker 1: source of very good feelings about ourself
Speaker 1: and about even life itself.
Speaker 1: We can feel from the positive ego, we can
Speaker 1: feel that life is good, it's good to be
Speaker 1: alive and life is good, it's good to be
Speaker 1: alive, and that life is good and it's a
Speaker 1: place of a source of appreciation and
Speaker 1: kindness.
Speaker 1: Also Because people have a lot of
Speaker 1: self-confidence and believe in themselves
Speaker 1: and realize their own inherent dignity and
Speaker 1: decency, have a room inside their souls and
Speaker 1: their hearts for other people.
Speaker 1: They tend to be kinder and more generous
Speaker 1: people, whereas people who are very angry
Speaker 1: and victimized and frustrated by life tend
Speaker 1: to be obsessed with their own unhappiness.
Speaker 1: They tend to have less time for the
Speaker 1: wellbeing of others.
Speaker 1: So the positive ego feels good.
Speaker 1: The negative ego feels bad.
Speaker 1: Now, if you pay attention to your
Speaker 1: experience, you tend to notice that one of
Speaker 1: those moments when you're feeling good
Speaker 1: about yourself, about your accomplishments,
Speaker 1: about your aspirations, that's coming from
Speaker 1: the positive ego.
Speaker 1: You should pay attention throughout the day
Speaker 1: when you're having these kinds of feelings.
Speaker 1: Where is it coming from?
Speaker 1: Oh, that's my positive ego.
Speaker 1: What does the positive ego feel like?
Speaker 1: The positive ego feels good.
Speaker 1: It feels good to be me.
Speaker 1: It feels good to be Andrew.
Speaker 1: I no longer hate myself.
Speaker 1: I like myself.
Speaker 1: I feel it feels good to be me.
Speaker 1: In all my imperfection, it feels good to be
Speaker 1: me.
Speaker 1: Fundamentally, it feels good to be me.
Speaker 1: It's the positive ego.
Speaker 1: The negative ego feels depressed, lonely,
Speaker 1: alienated, isolated, fearful, paranoid,
Speaker 1: doubtful, tempted by nihilistic thoughts,
Speaker 1: that kind of thing.
Speaker 1: So when you're not feeling good, when
Speaker 1: you're feeling depressed and lousy, pay
Speaker 1: attention to the source of the bad feelings
Speaker 1: and you'll notice that it's coming from a
Speaker 1: psychological self-structure that we're
Speaker 1: calling the negative ego.
Speaker 1: That is entertaining or seeing the human
Speaker 1: experience that you're having through
Speaker 1: particular structures of thinking,
Speaker 1: particular habit patterns and habitual
Speaker 1: structures of thinking.
Speaker 1: It gives you very bad feelings that are
Speaker 1: very familiar because they're very
Speaker 1: conditioned.
Speaker 1: And then, if you're good at paying
Speaker 1: attention to your own experience, if you're
Speaker 1: a good meditator, if you're a good
Speaker 1: self-observer, if you're inclined to really
Speaker 1: focus on what's happening as it's happening,
Speaker 1: you'll begin to notice these habitual
Speaker 1: patterns in your emotional experience.
Speaker 1: You're gonna start to notice that you feel
Speaker 1: bad because of particular ways of thinking.
Speaker 1: Habitual patterns of negative thinking
Speaker 1: create negative emotional responses in
Speaker 1: yourself.
Speaker 1: If you pay attention, you'll start to
Speaker 1: notice that you're feeling bad because of
Speaker 1: the way you're thinking and what you're
Speaker 1: thinking about it and the way you're
Speaker 1: thinking about it.
Speaker 1: It's something that you or we are doing to
Speaker 1: ourselves because it's become a habit, a
Speaker 1: bad habit.
Speaker 1: In the same way, if you're feeling good
Speaker 1: about yourself, about your positive ego, it
Speaker 1: has to do with the way that you're thinking
Speaker 1: about your own self, about you, the way, in
Speaker 1: my case, andrew's thinking about Andrew,
Speaker 1: the way I'm thinking about me.
Speaker 1: If I'm thinking in ways that are
Speaker 1: constructive and life affirming and
Speaker 1: inherently positive, I tend to feel good.
Speaker 1: So these different structures of ourself
Speaker 1: operate within us as habitual patterns of
Speaker 1: thinking, habitual tendencies to think in
Speaker 1: predictable patterns that have predictable
Speaker 1: emotional results.
Speaker 1: So usually, if you're feeling bad, it's
Speaker 1: because you've been dwelling on the way
Speaker 1: your negative ego feels about life.
Speaker 1: If you're feeling bad, it's because you're
Speaker 1: dwelling on how your negative ego feels
Speaker 1: about life.
Speaker 1: If you're feeling bad, it's because you're
Speaker 1: dwelling on how your negative ego feels
Speaker 1: about life Not a good thing to be doing.
Speaker 1: And if you're feeling good, it means you
Speaker 1: are delighting in how your positive ego
Speaker 1: feels about life.
Speaker 1: Now in the search for the awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightenment and the awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: There is a famous distinction made in
Speaker 1: Mahayana Buddhism.
Speaker 1: It's called the two-truth doctrine.
Speaker 1: According to the two-truth doctrine tells
Speaker 1: us that there is what's called relative
Speaker 1: reality and absolute reality.
Speaker 1: There's two fundamental distinctions in the
Speaker 1: experience of consciousness and cognition.
Speaker 1: One occurs in the relative context and the
Speaker 1: other occurs in the absolute context.
Speaker 1: So the small self that we experience as
Speaker 1: positive ego or negative ego exists in the
Speaker 1: relative category.
Speaker 1: So, according to the two-truth doctrine and
Speaker 1: the way I've been describing the ego so far,
Speaker 1: all the positive experiences and feelings
Speaker 1: and thoughts of the positive ego are
Speaker 1: occurring in a relative context and all of
Speaker 1: the negative thoughts and feelings of the
Speaker 1: negative ego are all occurring in a
Speaker 1: relative context.
Speaker 1: The negative ego are all occurring in a
Speaker 1: So when we wake up, when we have the
Speaker 1: experience of spiritual awakening, when we
Speaker 1: become conscious of consciousness, when we
Speaker 1: awaken to enlightened awareness, there's a
Speaker 1: shift from relative reality relative
Speaker 1: cognition to absolute reality and absolute
Speaker 1: cognition.
Speaker 1: The lights go on and suddenly we find we're
Speaker 1: in a completely seeing reality from the
Speaker 1: perspective of a completely different
Speaker 1: dimension of knowing and of being.
Speaker 1: So the enlightened awareness, the awareness
Speaker 1: of enlightenment or the experience or the
Speaker 1: presence of enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: The awareness of enlightenment or the
Speaker 1: experience or the presence of enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness emerges or becomes apparent to us
Speaker 1: when we make that flip from relative
Speaker 1: reality to absolute reality, from relative
Speaker 1: consciousness to absolute consciousness and
Speaker 1: relative cognition to absolute cognition,
Speaker 1: Like the lights go on.
Speaker 1: Now, in my experience, there are two
Speaker 1: experiences of the self that we come upon
Speaker 1: when lights go on, when we make that flip
Speaker 1: from relative reality to absolute reality,
Speaker 1: from relative consciousness to absolute
Speaker 1: consciousness, relative reality to absolute
Speaker 1: reality, from relative consciousness to
Speaker 1: absolute consciousness and relative
Speaker 1: cognition to absolute cognition.
Speaker 1: One is from the small self, which is the
Speaker 1: ego, to the true self, which all of you
Speaker 1: have already heard about.
Speaker 1: The true self, true self.
Speaker 1: So the true self is the experience of being.
Speaker 1: Being is the conscious knowing of the
Speaker 1: deepest dimension of reality that exists
Speaker 1: before the universe had even arisen as a
Speaker 1: thought in the mind of God.
Speaker 1: So being is that primordial ground from
Speaker 1: which all of reality emerges, and the
Speaker 1: conscious gnosis of being, the conscious
Speaker 1: experience of being, the conscious knowing
Speaker 1: of being, is the experience of peace.
Speaker 1: Before the universe was created, there was
Speaker 1: only peace, because before the universe was
Speaker 1: created nothing had happened.
Speaker 1: Things can only go wrong after the Big Bang.
Speaker 1: Before the universe was created, everything
Speaker 1: was quiet, peaceful, timeless and formless,
Speaker 1: and beginningless and endless, because
Speaker 1: before the universe was created there was
Speaker 1: no time and there was no space, there's no
Speaker 1: universe and there certainly was no you and
Speaker 1: no me.
Speaker 1: So when we awaken to the ground of all
Speaker 1: being, which Eckhart Tolle describes so
Speaker 1: beautifully, the ground of all being, when
Speaker 1: you and I awaken to the ground of all being,
Speaker 1: which Eckhart Tolle describes so
Speaker 1: beautifully, the ground of all being, when
Speaker 1: you and I awaken to the ground of all being,
Speaker 1: to that deepest dimension of reality that
Speaker 1: exists prior to the emergence of time and
Speaker 1: space, how do we know it?
Speaker 1: Because we suddenly experience at the level
Speaker 1: of the self.
Speaker 1: We experience overwhelming peace.
Speaker 1: An overwhelming peace, but it's a peace
Speaker 1: without any boundaries.
Speaker 1: It's a peace that exists everywhere and
Speaker 1: nowhere.
Speaker 1: It's a peace that is timeless and formless,
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless, birthless and
Speaker 1: deathless and infinite and eternal.
Speaker 1: So when we make that leap from a, that leap
Speaker 1: from the world of relative reality, where
Speaker 1: the ego dominates, and we awaken to the
Speaker 1: ground of eternity itself, it's quite a
Speaker 1: flip, it's quite a jump.
Speaker 1: It's not a small change of consciousness
Speaker 1: and cognition, it's an absolute leap beyond
Speaker 1: what the mind can even begin to imagine.
Speaker 1: It's not a small, subtle shift, it's an
Speaker 1: absolute transformation.
Speaker 1: So the truth, what's generally called the
Speaker 1: true self, feels like peace, and this is
Speaker 1: very important to understand this, because
Speaker 1: I'm trying to describe in this talk how the
Speaker 1: self feels, which means how I feel.
Speaker 1: What does it feel like to be me?
Speaker 1: The question is well, what does it feel
Speaker 1: like to be you, andrew?
Speaker 1: What does it feel like to be any one of us?
Speaker 1: The question is well, what does it feel
Speaker 1: like to be you, andrew?
Speaker 1: What does it feel like to be any one of us?
Speaker 1: The question is well, what does it feel
Speaker 1: like to be me?
Speaker 1: Which part of me are you referring to?
Speaker 1: Are you referring to my positive ego, my
Speaker 1: negative ego, my true self?
Speaker 1: Because they all feel very different.
Speaker 1: So what's important to understand here is
Speaker 1: that the true self, which is the conscious
Speaker 1: gnosis of the ground of all being, being,
Speaker 1: exists prior to anything and everything
Speaker 1: else that we can imagine, exists prior to
Speaker 1: time and space, prior to the emergence of
Speaker 1: the evolving universe.
Speaker 1: So, because the ground of being exists
Speaker 1: prior to all things, it's a place and a
Speaker 1: space, a dimension and a reality in which
Speaker 1: nothing has ever happened.
Speaker 1: Nothing has ever happened, nothing has ever
Speaker 1: happened.
Speaker 1: So in that mysterious dimension where
Speaker 1: nothing's ever happened, nothing is wrong,
Speaker 1: nothing could be wrong, because nothing
Speaker 1: could have gone wrong yet, because nothing
Speaker 1: happened yet.
Speaker 1: So it's important to understand that the
Speaker 1: conscious knows, as the conscious awakening
Speaker 1: to the ground of all being, what's called
Speaker 1: the ground of all being.
Speaker 1: To repeat, it's their awakening to the
Speaker 1: ground of all being, what's called the
Speaker 1: ground of all being.
Speaker 1: To repeat, it's their awakening to the
Speaker 1: deepest dimension of reality that exists
Speaker 1: prior to the emergence of time and space
Speaker 1: and the whole universe.
Speaker 1: So before time and space, before the
Speaker 1: universe came into being, there was only
Speaker 1: being.
Speaker 1: There was no thing else.
Speaker 1: So being can be called nothingness,
Speaker 1: emptiness, primordial emptiness, primordial
Speaker 1: voidness, nothingness.
Speaker 1: But the flip here is going from relative
Speaker 1: consciousness and relative cognition,
Speaker 1: relative knowing, the absolute
Speaker 1: consciousness, absolute cognition and
Speaker 1: absolute knowing.
Speaker 1: So it's a leap into eternity, the conscious
Speaker 1: gnosis, the conscious recognition, the
Speaker 1: waking to eternity.
Speaker 1: What does eternity mean?
Speaker 1: Eternity means timeless and formless,
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless, birthless and
Speaker 1: deathless, infinite and the true self.
Speaker 1: When you awaken to the true self, the true
Speaker 1: self feels like you, but it's not the same
Speaker 1: you.
Speaker 1: This is you as liberated, emancipated,
Speaker 1: eternal knowing, being, feeling.
Speaker 1: So suddenly it feels very different to be
Speaker 1: any one of us.
Speaker 1: It feels very different to be Andrew and in
Speaker 1: that state of us it feels very different to
Speaker 1: be Andrew.
Speaker 1: And in that state of consciousness, and the
Speaker 1: happy, the feelings of happiness and the
Speaker 1: happy ego become meaningless, because the
Speaker 1: narrative of Andrew's story becomes
Speaker 1: meaningless in that context.
Speaker 1: And it is a great relief to put down the
Speaker 1: burden of being Andrew, even the happy
Speaker 1: Andrew.
Speaker 1: It's a great burden, in that state of
Speaker 1: consciousness, to put down all of his
Speaker 1: suitcases and his belongings, to be free of
Speaker 1: all of it as belongings, to be free of all
Speaker 1: of it and to experience the unimaginable
Speaker 1: purity of never having been born and never
Speaker 1: having entered the stream of time.
Speaker 1: It's a place where there is no karma and
Speaker 1: the experience of that kind of freedom is
Speaker 1: unimaginable to the ego, even to the
Speaker 1: positive ego.
Speaker 1: It's unimaginable Because it's a different
Speaker 1: order of human experience, it's a different
Speaker 1: order of context.
Speaker 1: So so the positive ego feels good about
Speaker 1: itself and about life in a relative context.
Speaker 1: The negative ego feels bad about itself and
Speaker 1: ambivalent about life, to say the least, in
Speaker 1: a relative context.
Speaker 1: But the true self experiences the ecstasy
Speaker 1: of being or non-being in an absolute
Speaker 1: context.
Speaker 1: This is what some people call
Speaker 1: superconsciousness, and it becomes
Speaker 1: superconsciousness versus relative
Speaker 1: consciousness because in that leap it had
Speaker 1: flipped from relative or relative context
Speaker 1: to an absolute context.
Speaker 1: But the true self feels very particular.
Speaker 1: When someone awakens to their true self,
Speaker 1: you can see a particular look, they start
Speaker 1: to look a particular way.
Speaker 1: Their eyes, the look in their eye, changes,
Speaker 1: they calm down and they slow down and
Speaker 1: they're seeing you from a space and a place
Speaker 1: of infinite depth that can't be measured.
Speaker 1: And in that state of consciousness all of
Speaker 1: the fears and concerns of the small self
Speaker 1: are nowhere to be found.
Speaker 1: They don't exist Because, remember, in the
Speaker 1: context of the true self nothing has ever
Speaker 1: happened.
Speaker 1: So because nothing has ever happened, one
Speaker 1: is uncorrupted.
Speaker 1: In that state it's before the corruption
Speaker 1: and the damage has happened.
Speaker 1: And that's when we all become very
Speaker 1: delightful people.
Speaker 1: The best people to hang out with, the best
Speaker 1: people to hang out with and spend time with
Speaker 1: are those people who are awake to their
Speaker 1: true self.
Speaker 1: Because when you make that flip from
Speaker 1: relative to absolute consciousness, you
Speaker 1: become utterly absorbed in how
Speaker 1: extraordinary it is to be conscious of
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: That in itself is a completely.
Speaker 1: It's an overwhelming experience and it's an
Speaker 1: overwhelming recognition in which all of
Speaker 1: your relative needs seem to disappear I
Speaker 1: need to do this and I need to do that, and
Speaker 1: I have to have this and I have to have that
Speaker 1: All gone, and I have to have this and I
Speaker 1: have to have that All gone and that state,
Speaker 1: consciousness to consciousness itself,
Speaker 1: becomes its own delight.
Speaker 1: So that's a flip from relative to absolute.
Speaker 1: So I was talking about the ego, the happy
Speaker 1: ego, the unhappy ego and the true self.
Speaker 1: There's one more, which I like to call the
Speaker 1: authentic self.
Speaker 1: So the authentic self is the experience of
Speaker 1: liberation, liberated consciousness, that
Speaker 1: we find when we enter into what's called
Speaker 1: flow states, whether we're skiing or
Speaker 1: playing a musical instrument, making love,
Speaker 1: reading poetry or simply out for a walk in
Speaker 1: nature.
Speaker 1: But when we enter into a sublime state of
Speaker 1: flow, we suddenly become aware of the
Speaker 1: movement of the cosmos within us and all
Speaker 1: around us.
Speaker 1: So the source of this flow state within us
Speaker 1: and all around us, so the source of this
Speaker 1: flow state, in my thinking, is the.
Speaker 1: We call it the evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 1: It's the conscious recognition, the
Speaker 1: conscious awakening to and the cognizance
Speaker 1: of the energy and intelligence that created
Speaker 1: the universe, that creative evolutionary
Speaker 1: spark that compelled the universe into
Speaker 1: being, it's the urge towards creativity,
Speaker 1: it's that which compels us to be creative
Speaker 1: and to create.
Speaker 1: When any one of us awakens to our own
Speaker 1: unique gifts of creative gifts, our gifts
Speaker 1: to give rise to as yet unmanifest
Speaker 1: possibilities, when those new potentials
Speaker 1: start manifesting through us, whether it
Speaker 1: doesn't matter, it doesn't matter what the
Speaker 1: context is it could be science or music,
Speaker 1: medicine or, as I said before, poetry we
Speaker 1: become one with the dance of the universe.
Speaker 1: We become aware that the whole universe, in
Speaker 1: that state of consciousness, we become
Speaker 1: aware of the fact that the whole universe,
Speaker 1: in that state of consciousness, we become
Speaker 1: from the perspective of that state of
Speaker 1: consciousness, the whole universe, is one
Speaker 1: evolving self-aware being.
Speaker 1: The universe is a conscious, self-aware
Speaker 1: being.
Speaker 1: The universe, which is a self-aware being,
Speaker 1: is not a static being but is a being.
Speaker 1: Thataware being is not a static being but
Speaker 1: is in a being that is part of a development,
Speaker 1: that is part of a developmental process,
Speaker 1: that is a developmental process in progress.
Speaker 1: And when you're in that state of
Speaker 1: consciousness, you can see and you can feel
Speaker 1: the ecstatic urgency of becoming, the
Speaker 1: becoming of the cosmos, the becoming of the
Speaker 1: universe, becoming more of who and what it
Speaker 1: can be through you and through me.
Speaker 1: I am and you are the energy and
Speaker 1: intelligence that created the universe,
Speaker 1: awakening to itself through the body, mind
Speaker 1: and personality of myself or yourself.
Speaker 1: This is when the universe becomes
Speaker 1: self-aware and personality of myself or
Speaker 1: yourself, this is when the universe becomes
Speaker 1: self-aware.
Speaker 1: So the universe becomes self-aware through
Speaker 1: us, through the expanded state of
Speaker 1: consciousness in which we become aware of
Speaker 1: this movement towards greater complexity,
Speaker 1: the movement towards higher and higher and
Speaker 1: more complex possibilities of what's called
Speaker 1: emergence.
Speaker 1: So when we become aware in this way of the
Speaker 1: universe becoming self-aware through us, of
Speaker 1: its own dynamic creativity, there is the
Speaker 1: thrilling recognition that we are part and
Speaker 1: parcel of a cosmic process that had a
Speaker 1: beginning in time.
Speaker 1: That's definitely going somewhere new.
Speaker 1: It's on the infinite journey of
Speaker 1: self-becoming, of self-creating.
Speaker 1: And when highly sophisticated self-aware
Speaker 1: human beings awaken in this way, the
Speaker 1: universe becomes conscious of itself
Speaker 1: through them.
Speaker 1: And that's when there's the awakening to
Speaker 1: evolutionary non-duality.
Speaker 1: Evolutionary non-duality, that's when we
Speaker 1: realize that I am.
Speaker 1: That means I am the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that created the universe, awakening to
Speaker 1: itself through the body-mind personality of
Speaker 1: myself.
Speaker 1: I am the universe becoming conscious of
Speaker 1: itself through me, and that's a pretty big
Speaker 1: recognition.
Speaker 1: And that's a pretty big recognition.
Speaker 1: It's a pretty big recognition.
Speaker 1: And this kind of recognition, this kind of
Speaker 1: state of consciousness, this kind of
Speaker 1: knowledge, this is called the awakening to
Speaker 1: what I call the authentic self.
Speaker 1: The awakening to the true self is very,
Speaker 1: very different.
Speaker 1: The awakening to the true self is.
Speaker 1: The awakening to the true self is very,
Speaker 1: very different.
Speaker 1: The awakening to the true self is the
Speaker 1: awakening to static, eternal being.
Speaker 1: Being isn't going anywhere.
Speaker 1: It is not a journey of becoming.
Speaker 1: Being simply is eternally itself.
Speaker 1: Being is static knowing, but in being there
Speaker 1: is no becoming.
Speaker 1: So being is eternity consciousness, an
Speaker 1: experience of eternity consciousness that
Speaker 1: is static, and experience of eternity
Speaker 1: consciousness that is static, that's the
Speaker 1: true self.
Speaker 1: The awakening to the authentic self is the
Speaker 1: awakening to the evolutionary impulse, the
Speaker 1: ecstatic urgency that gave rise to the
Speaker 1: entire creative process.
Speaker 1: That's an explosion in motion.
Speaker 1: So we're all part and parcel of an
Speaker 1: explosion in motion.
Speaker 1: When you become conscious of the explosion
Speaker 1: in motion, you realize you are that
Speaker 1: explosion in motion.
Speaker 1: Then you realize something else, which is
Speaker 1: that the explosion in motion needs your own
Speaker 1: conscious participation in it in order for
Speaker 1: the explosion in motion needs your own
Speaker 1: conscious participation in it, in order for
Speaker 1: the explosion in motion to continue to
Speaker 1: expand and on its own journey of
Speaker 1: complexification, we get to see how your
Speaker 1: own presence here in the universe is not
Speaker 1: arbitrary, as some would like to believe,
Speaker 1: but it's inherently purposeful.
Speaker 1: And when you awaken to the fact that your
Speaker 1: presence here in the universe is inherently
Speaker 1: purposeful, this is liberating indeed, and
Speaker 1: so spiritually empowering, so profoundly
Speaker 1: spiritually empowering.
Speaker 1: So what does the authentic self feel like?
Speaker 1: What does the authentic self feel like?
Speaker 1: What does your authentic self feel like?
Speaker 1: Turned on, excited and big time inspired,
Speaker 1: inspired, inspired.
Speaker 1: When you're awake to your authentic self,
Speaker 1: you are burning with evolutionary
Speaker 1: inspiration, evolutionary conviction and
Speaker 1: evolutionary commitment.
Speaker 1: You know who you are and you know why
Speaker 1: you're here and you're committed.
Speaker 1: You're committed, you're committed for the
Speaker 1: long haul.
Speaker 1: And if we look at the meaning of the long
Speaker 1: haul in an evolutionary framework, long
Speaker 1: haul it could mean forever, if not forever
Speaker 1: for a very long time, but it might as well
Speaker 1: be forever.
Speaker 1: It means you're committed.
Speaker 1: I'm here, baby, I'm fully here.
Speaker 1: I'm here for the long haul.
Speaker 1: Now that I'm awakened to who I really am, I
Speaker 1: realize how much I'm awakened to who I
Speaker 1: really am.
Speaker 1: I realize how much I'm needed and that the
Speaker 1: emergence of life and eventually the
Speaker 1: emergence of conscious life has not been a
Speaker 1: random accident at all.
Speaker 1: This was inevitably, this was inevitable
Speaker 1: and predetermined from the very beginning.
Speaker 1: When you become conscious of all the things
Speaker 1: I'm describing, that becomes obvious.
Speaker 1: Consciousness in the capacity of
Speaker 1: consciousness is far from an accident.
Speaker 1: It's a driver of the whole process.
Speaker 1: An accident, so drive over the whole
Speaker 1: process.
Speaker 1: But for the consciousness of consciousness
Speaker 1: to mean something, you, whoever you are,
Speaker 1: and me, whoever I am, when we awaken we
Speaker 1: have to be ready to say yes and to respond
Speaker 1: to what we're realizing and to be committed
Speaker 1: to the evolution of the interior of the
Speaker 1: whole cosmos.
Speaker 1: And I hope you can see, when I'm speaking
Speaker 1: this way, that this leap from relative
Speaker 1: consciousness, relative cognition, to
Speaker 1: absolute consciousness and absolute
Speaker 1: cognition is the most radical flip of
Speaker 1: context and perspective imaginable.
Speaker 1: And if you are spiritually evolved enough
Speaker 1: to be able to say yes and to surrender, at
Speaker 1: that point and you're off to the races.
Speaker 1: Your feet have landed on the yonder shore
Speaker 1: and now you become a co-creator of the
Speaker 1: cosmos with the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that gave rise to it in the first place,
Speaker 1: which is you anyway.
Speaker 1: So four selves, getting back to the main
Speaker 1: topic of this talk.
Speaker 1: So there's the happy ego and the unhappy
Speaker 1: ego, the true self and the authentic self.
Speaker 1: The happy ego feels good about itself and
Speaker 1: positive about life in a relative context.
Speaker 1: The negative ego feels bad about itself and
Speaker 1: bad about life in a relative context.
Speaker 1: The true self experiences unconditional,
Speaker 1: absolute freedom in an absolute context.
Speaker 1: And the authentic self experiences ecstatic,
Speaker 1: creative urgency in an absolute context.
Speaker 1: Now, these four cells that I'm describing,
Speaker 1: you all will be able to locate in your own
Speaker 1: self-experience.
Speaker 1: I'm sure the first two, but I'm sure the
Speaker 1: happy ego and the unhappy ego, are more
Speaker 1: available to all of you than the other two,
Speaker 1: the two but as your spiritual practice
Speaker 1: deepens and as your experience of higher
Speaker 1: consciousness develops, you begin to become
Speaker 1: familiar with the true self.
Speaker 1: I'm speaking about the authentic self I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about, and so the happy ego and
Speaker 1: the positive ego feels very specific, very
Speaker 1: particular.
Speaker 1: It's a unique feeling.
Speaker 1: It's a unique self-feeling unto itself.
Speaker 1: I had a good day, I had a good workout, I
Speaker 1: had a good experience.
Speaker 1: I feel good about being me in this world
Speaker 1: and life is good.
Speaker 1: Happy ego I've had a terrible day and I
Speaker 1: feel really bad about being me, and we know
Speaker 1: what that feels like.
Speaker 1: When we wake into the true self, we
Speaker 1: experience freedom from all the
Speaker 1: constrictions of the ego, positive and
Speaker 1: negative, and the feeling is an
Speaker 1: unconditional freedom.
Speaker 1: I've never been born and I've never entered
Speaker 1: the stream of time and nothing ever
Speaker 1: happened.
Speaker 1: There never was a problem that needed to be
Speaker 1: overcome, and I know that now that enables
Speaker 1: us to let go of everything and the
Speaker 1: authentic self, in the authentic self, we
Speaker 1: feel an overwhelming sense of, we get into
Speaker 1: an overwhelming sense of going into an
Speaker 1: overwhelming sense of responsibility for
Speaker 1: the evolution of the cosmos, and it's when
Speaker 1: we experience a great sense of alignment
Speaker 1: with the cosmos and with the forces of the
Speaker 1: evolutionary intelligence is driving the
Speaker 1: whole process.
Speaker 1: That's where we wake to this great sense of
Speaker 1: responsibility for being here.
Speaker 1: So that's the general idea, but there's one
Speaker 1: more piece of this picture which makes it a
Speaker 1: little bit more complicated.
Speaker 1: So I made this distinction several times as
Speaker 1: I've been speaking that the the positive
Speaker 1: ego and the negative ego appear in a
Speaker 1: context that's relative and that the true
Speaker 1: self and the authentic self appear in a
Speaker 1: context that's non-relative or absolute,
Speaker 1: which is true.
Speaker 1: But just to make this a little bit more
Speaker 1: complex but understandable, is that the
Speaker 1: what I'm calling the true self and the
Speaker 1: authentic self usually awaken or become
Speaker 1: apparent through the ego structure that
Speaker 1: we're calling the positive ego, because,
Speaker 1: remember, the ego, which is what we call
Speaker 1: the frontal self, is a self-structure.
Speaker 1: It's a personality structure, a
Speaker 1: self-structure, a personality structure
Speaker 1: through which consciousness is transmitted.
Speaker 1: So, in this case, I want us to see the
Speaker 1: structure of the ego or the frontal self as
Speaker 1: a portal, the ego or the frontal self as a
Speaker 1: portal, the structure or a portal through
Speaker 1: which these higher self capacities appear.
Speaker 1: So, for example, if you, if you have an
Speaker 1: experience of in this case you'd say, well,
Speaker 1: if Andrew has an experience of the
Speaker 1: emergence of the presence of the true self,
Speaker 1: the true self would appear, would show up
Speaker 1: through the frontal self structure of
Speaker 1: Andrew's personality, and so the question
Speaker 1: would become well, was it still Andrew?
Speaker 1: And so the question would become well, was
Speaker 1: it still Andrew?
Speaker 1: And you would probably say, well, it was
Speaker 1: his voice, it was his mind.
Speaker 1: I could recognize his mind and his voice
Speaker 1: and his memory was there, but and it seemed
Speaker 1: like it was him but he was so different
Speaker 1: because he seemed fearless and cognizant of
Speaker 1: an infinite context that, in his relative
Speaker 1: consciousness, he doesn't seem to be aware
Speaker 1: of.
Speaker 1: So, yes, it was still Andrew, but now
Speaker 1: Andrew was full of the consciousness of
Speaker 1: eternity.
Speaker 1: So in this, what I'm describing to you, in
Speaker 1: this case, the positive ego becomes, in
Speaker 1: this awakened context, the structure or the
Speaker 1: portal through which this true self emerges,
Speaker 1: self emerges.
Speaker 1: So you could say that in this case, in the
Speaker 1: way I'm describing this, that the ego is
Speaker 1: still present, but it becomes transmuted or
Speaker 1: overwhelmed by the presence of this non
Speaker 1: relative or absolute dimension of the true
Speaker 1: self.
Speaker 1: And the same thing is true about the
Speaker 1: authentic self.
Speaker 1: We can awaken, we can have.
Speaker 1: We can have, we can awaken to the energy
Speaker 1: and intelligence that created the universe,
Speaker 1: the evolutionary impulse, in a way that is
Speaker 1: mild and subtle or in a way that is
Speaker 1: completely overwhelming and intense.
Speaker 1: So you can say, was Andrew still there?
Speaker 1: You say yes, it was.
Speaker 1: His voice, his mind, his personality I can
Speaker 1: recognize.
Speaker 1: But there was an evolutionary passion, a
Speaker 1: fearless evolutionary passion, and an
Speaker 1: ecstatic creativity and care for the
Speaker 1: evolution of the interior of the cosmos
Speaker 1: that he was expressing.
Speaker 1: That's very different than his ordinary
Speaker 1: state.
Speaker 1: So the point I'm trying to make here,
Speaker 1: that's very different than his ordinary
Speaker 1: state.
Speaker 1: So the point I'm trying to make here is
Speaker 1: that the positive ego tends to be the
Speaker 1: frontal self-structure or the portal
Speaker 1: through which these higher self-potentials
Speaker 1: emerge through us into present reality.
Speaker 1: And then, finally, if the experience of the
Speaker 1: presence of the true self and the authentic
Speaker 1: self is particularly intense which can
Speaker 1: happen to some people sometimes, when the
Speaker 1: emergence of the true self and the
Speaker 1: authentic self is particularly intense, it
Speaker 1: can happen that the frontal ego structure
Speaker 1: in this case Andrew or anybody else could
Speaker 1: or would temporarily disappear altogether.
Speaker 1: And then you say, well, andrew wasn't there
Speaker 1: anymore, could or would temporarily
Speaker 1: disappear altogether.
Speaker 1: And then you say, well, andrew wasn't there
Speaker 1: anymore.
Speaker 1: There was just the forceful presence, the
Speaker 1: overwhelming presence of the absolute was
Speaker 1: coming through him so powerfully that I
Speaker 1: couldn't find him anymore.
Speaker 1: He seemed to be completely gone.
Speaker 1: Or if it was the authentic self, you could
Speaker 1: say the force of evolution itself, the
Speaker 1: energy and intelligence of the evolutionary
Speaker 1: force driving the universe, was all I could
Speaker 1: see and feel.
Speaker 1: I couldn't see him anymore.
Speaker 1: It seemed to me that something was coming
Speaker 1: through him, and that can also happen that
Speaker 1: temporarily, the facade, the facade this is
Speaker 1: just a facade, facade temporarily the
Speaker 1: facade of the egoic self-structure can
Speaker 1: disappear altogether.
Speaker 1: And if you ever see anybody or with someone
Speaker 1: who has gone that deep, it can be utterly
Speaker 1: inspiring and also a little frightening
Speaker 1: sometimes.
Speaker 1: So I think so.
Speaker 1: Why I like to speak about these
Speaker 1: distinctions is because a lot of us who are
Speaker 1: interested in enlightenment often hear
Speaker 1: about who I really am and all that kind of
Speaker 1: thing, and the way I think is the most
Speaker 1: helpful way to think about who I really am
Speaker 1: is to do this hard spiritual work of
Speaker 1: familiarizing yourselves with these four
Speaker 1: different dimensions of your own self and
Speaker 1: your own spiritual potential.
Speaker 1: Because and your own spiritual potential?
Speaker 1: Because we shouldn't speak too confidently
Speaker 1: about the presence of the true self, of who
Speaker 1: I really am, unless that is an aspect, a
Speaker 1: dimension of our own self that we actually
Speaker 1: have awakened to or can awaken to, because
Speaker 1: if you're speaking about awakening, coming
Speaker 1: from your true self, what you really do
Speaker 1: it's just your ego talking.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean anything.
Speaker 1: So we want to make it real.
Speaker 1: That's the whole idea, is to make it real.
Speaker 1: So that's why I often encourage people to
Speaker 1: do the kinds of spiritual work that's
Speaker 1: necessary to familiarize yourself between
Speaker 1: the difference between the positive ego and
Speaker 1: the negative ego, so you can become an
Speaker 1: expert on yourself, so you can become an
Speaker 1: expert on your own self, so you'll know who
Speaker 1: you are in any given moment because of how
Speaker 1: you feel.
Speaker 1: Where is the I am vibrating?
Speaker 1: Is the I am vibrating in the positive ego?
Speaker 1: Is the I am vibrating in the negative ego?
Speaker 1: Is the I am vibrating in the true self or
Speaker 1: is it vibrating in the authentic self?
Speaker 1: And becoming familiar with these
Speaker 1: distinctions, these different dimensions of
Speaker 1: your own self, can give you an enormous
Speaker 1: amount of spiritual self-confidence, what I
Speaker 1: call spiritual self-confidence, when you
Speaker 1: really know who you are and who you can be,
Speaker 1: and who you are in your best moments.
Speaker 1: In a way that is not wishy-washy, it's not
Speaker 1: vague, because what I'm trying to describe
Speaker 1: to you is very concrete.
Speaker 1: It's very concrete in my own experience.
Speaker 1: I'm not making this stuff up, I'm
Speaker 1: describing how I feel from the vantage
Speaker 1: point of my positive ego, negative ego,
Speaker 1: true self and authentic self.
Speaker 1: And I've noticed that the people who are
Speaker 1: familiar with this work and do the practice
Speaker 1: awaken in similar ways.
Speaker 1: And do the practice awaken in similar ways.
Speaker 1: And especially if we're interested in, if
Speaker 1: we're seriously interested in, evolutionary
Speaker 1: transformation and awakening to mind
Speaker 1: awareness, we have to be so committed to
Speaker 1: these different quadrants, these different
Speaker 1: dimensions of ourself, so committed to
Speaker 1: dimensions of ourself we experience very
Speaker 1: regularly, because the thing we need to
Speaker 1: experience these higher dimensions of
Speaker 1: ourself very regularly, because unless we
Speaker 1: do, we'll begin to forget that they exist.
Speaker 1: Because in this leap from relative reality
Speaker 1: and relative cognition to absolute reality
Speaker 1: and absolute cognition is that it's a leap
Speaker 1: from.
Speaker 1: It's a leap of context, from relative to
Speaker 1: absolute.
Speaker 1: And the relative context of the ego,
Speaker 1: whether it's a positive ego or negative ego,
Speaker 1: has no access to the absolute context.
Speaker 1: The true self and the authentic self can,
Speaker 1: if need be, see the world, see the relative
Speaker 1: world, but the relative world of the happy
Speaker 1: ego and the unhappy ego can't see the
Speaker 1: absolute context of the true self and the
Speaker 1: authentic self.
Speaker 1: So, unless we have these kinds of
Speaker 1: experiences of the true self and authentic
Speaker 1: self on a regular basis, we will tend to
Speaker 1: lose access to them and tend to forget why
Speaker 1: they're so important, lose access to them
Speaker 1: and tend to forget why they're so important.
Speaker 1: And that's one of the scary things about
Speaker 1: awakening, it's one of the frightening
Speaker 1: parts of all this is that, as I think the
Speaker 1: Buddha said, as nirvana has no beginning
Speaker 1: and no end, so samsara also has no
Speaker 1: beginning and no end, so samsara also has
Speaker 1: no beginning and no end.
Speaker 1: So the relative context, in the way I'm
Speaker 1: speaking now, the relative context is
Speaker 1: considered to be samsara.
Speaker 1: So if we take that statement as nirvana has
Speaker 1: no beginning and no end, so samsara has no
Speaker 1: beginning and no end, you have to think
Speaker 1: about what that means.
Speaker 1: That means when you're in the ego's world.
Speaker 1: When you're in the ego's world, whether
Speaker 1: it's positive or negative, it's its own
Speaker 1: eternal, it becomes its own what seems like
Speaker 1: eternal domain.
Speaker 1: So when you are fundamentally identified
Speaker 1: with the eternal domain, the eternal
Speaker 1: samsaric domain of the relative ego,
Speaker 1: whether positive or negative, that's all
Speaker 1: that's real.
Speaker 1: And in the state of the positive ego and
Speaker 1: the negative ego, it's almost impossible to
Speaker 1: even imagine that there is a non-relative
Speaker 1: absolute context that exists far beyond it.
Speaker 1: So as nirvana has no beginning in the wind,
Speaker 1: samsara has no beginning in the wind also.
Speaker 1: So that's what's so delicate and precarious
Speaker 1: about being on the spiritual path in
Speaker 1: earnest is that we can awaken and realize
Speaker 1: and discover so much that is absolute and
Speaker 1: life-changing and in the same way we can
Speaker 1: lose touch with it and lose access and
Speaker 1: forget and fall, fall out of heaven back
Speaker 1: into hell.
Speaker 1: So a big part of spiritual practice, as I
Speaker 1: understand it, requires us to pay a great
Speaker 1: deal of attention to our experience.
Speaker 1: To pay a great deal of attention to our
Speaker 1: experience, to repeat, to pay a great deal
Speaker 1: of attention to our experience and to
Speaker 1: really scrutinize our experience from
Speaker 1: moment to moment.
Speaker 1: Who am I now?
Speaker 1: Oh, I know who I am.
Speaker 1: That's my negative ego, uh-huh.
Speaker 1: So if you're in your negative ego, it's
Speaker 1: better to keep your mouth shut, don't you
Speaker 1: think?
Speaker 1: Always a good idea If you find that you're,
Speaker 1: for whatever reason.
Speaker 1: We don't want to blame anybody for anything,
Speaker 1: but if you find it, for whatever reason,
Speaker 1: that you are dwelling and abiding and
Speaker 1: hanging out in your negative ego, better
Speaker 1: not to say anything to anybody until you
Speaker 1: get the heck out of there and crawl back up
Speaker 1: to your positive ego.
Speaker 1: And if you say, where am I now?
Speaker 1: And you notice you're in your positive ego,
Speaker 1: which is always a good thing, realize, yeah,
Speaker 1: it's good, but it's only the positive ego,
Speaker 1: it's only relative.
Speaker 1: The positive ego is infinitely better than
Speaker 1: your negative ego, any day of the week, any
Speaker 1: time of the day, but it's still merely and
Speaker 1: only relative.
Speaker 1: And when you're awakened to your true self
Speaker 1: and you experience the ecstasy of timeless,
Speaker 1: formless, beginningless and endless eternal
Speaker 1: being and the rapture of eternal being,
Speaker 1: remember, if you can in that state, that
Speaker 1: that is not the whole picture either that
Speaker 1: God has two aspects.
Speaker 1: God, which means that which is absolute,
Speaker 1: has two aspects, and one is being and the
Speaker 1: other is becoming.
Speaker 1: So the rapture and peace of the unborn is
Speaker 1: only half the picture, and the other half
Speaker 1: of the picture is the ecstasy of eternal
Speaker 1: becoming.
Speaker 1: So we want to learn how to be masters of
Speaker 1: this process through diligently engaging
Speaker 1: with spiritual practice, and more than
Speaker 1: spiritual practice, which is kind of a
Speaker 1: banal phrase these days, I think.
Speaker 1: What does it really mean For me?
Speaker 1: It really means that unless you one is
Speaker 1: deadly serious about the transformational
Speaker 1: process, unless one is deadly serious about
Speaker 1: the transformational process, unless one is
Speaker 1: deadly serious about your own potential for
Speaker 1: transformation, unless you're willing to
Speaker 1: take yourself very seriously for all the
Speaker 1: right reasons, not the wrong reasons,
Speaker 1: because, as you all know, from the
Speaker 1: perspective of the negative ego, the
Speaker 1: wretched negative ego, we all take
Speaker 1: ourselves way too seriously for all the
Speaker 1: wrong reasons.
Speaker 1: Bad idea, but a much better idea is to
Speaker 1: learn through practice how to take
Speaker 1: ourselves seriously, deadly serious, for
Speaker 1: all the right reasons.
Speaker 1: We have to realize we all have this
Speaker 1: potential for profound transformation.
Speaker 1: Everybody has that potential within them.
Speaker 1: Everybody has that potential within them,
Speaker 1: but most people either don't believe it or
Speaker 1: they squander it.
Speaker 1: So realize you have that potential within
Speaker 1: yourself and don't squander it.
Speaker 1: Take it seriously, take yourself seriously,
Speaker 1: take your true self.
Speaker 1: Take your potential to awaken to your true
Speaker 1: self seriously, take your potential to
Speaker 1: awaken to your authentic self seriously,
Speaker 1: because if you do, it'll change your life
Speaker 1: and the whole.
Speaker 1: And with the Enlightenment Project, which
Speaker 1: has been online for the last three or 4,000
Speaker 1: years, 5,000 years, make no mistake about
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: To repeat what I said several times, this,
Speaker 1: this, this flip of this leap from relative
Speaker 1: reality and relative cognition to absolute
Speaker 1: reality and absolute cognition, that's the
Speaker 1: whole ballgame.
Speaker 1: It's that flip.
Speaker 1: That's the flip that changes everything.
Speaker 1: And it changes everything Meaning.
Speaker 1: It changes everything meaning your.
Speaker 1: It means your fundamental existential
Speaker 1: relationship to existence, your fundamental
Speaker 1: existential relationship to being here.
Speaker 1: It's enormous.
Speaker 1: So for me, the whole practice quote unquote
Speaker 1: is dependent upon you or me, any one of us,
Speaker 1: taking ourselves seriously for all the
Speaker 1: right reasons.
Speaker 1: Because if it's true what the man said,
Speaker 1: that as nirvana has no beginning and end,
Speaker 1: so samsara has no beginning and end, we
Speaker 1: have to be careful about what we're doing
Speaker 1: and very careful.
Speaker 1: If you pay attention to these different
Speaker 1: dimensions of your own self.
Speaker 1: You won't need a psychotherapist, because
Speaker 1: what's more important than the content of
Speaker 1: your consciousness, what's more important
Speaker 1: than the content of your thinking, is where
Speaker 1: it's coming from.
Speaker 1: What's the source of the thoughts?
Speaker 1: If they have a good source, then all is
Speaker 1: good.
Speaker 1: If they have a bad source, don't believe
Speaker 1: any of it.
Speaker 1: But it takes a lot of courage to do this,
Speaker 1: because we, unless we take ourselves deadly
Speaker 1: seriously, unless we take our own potential
Speaker 1: for liberation seriously, we're always
Speaker 1: going to be interested in the details, but,
Speaker 1: but, but, but, but.
Speaker 1: And the negative ego is always interested
Speaker 1: in the details, insisting on the details.
Speaker 1: It doesn't matter, it's all garbage anyway,
Speaker 1: but this little piece of garbage is very
Speaker 1: important.
Speaker 1: Say no, it's not, because it's garbage.
Speaker 1: Because it's garbage, it becomes irrelevant.
Speaker 1: And then we see how messed up we really are,
Speaker 1: because we're holding up a piece of garbage
Speaker 1: that's dirty and smells bad and we don't
Speaker 1: want to give up.
Speaker 1: That's the definition of crazy, right,
Speaker 1: right, that's the definition of crazy right.
Speaker 1: So a big part of this kind of growth
Speaker 1: process is learning how to become more
Speaker 1: cognizant of the contexts, the inner
Speaker 1: context in which we're swimming and where
Speaker 1: we're locating ourself, what we're
Speaker 1: identifying with.
Speaker 1: Where are we, where am I, where are we?
Speaker 1: And the reason why the meditation process
Speaker 1: is so important is it can help us to get
Speaker 1: out of this ego field, even the positive
Speaker 1: ego.
Speaker 1: And it can help us to get out of this ego
Speaker 1: field, even the positive ego.
Speaker 1: Because even things that seem very
Speaker 1: important to the positive ego, which is
Speaker 1: usually all positive stuff, when you wake
Speaker 1: up to the true self or the authentic self,
Speaker 1: suddenly you realize, yeah, yeah, but it's
Speaker 1: all relative, so it doesn't matter.
Speaker 1: That's the whole point.
Speaker 1: That's the big leap from samsara to nirvana.
Speaker 1: Now imagine what it would be like if we had
Speaker 1: a friendship and we made an agreement with
Speaker 1: each other, say, andrew, I'm not going to
Speaker 1: talk to you, I'm just making this up.
Speaker 1: It's kind of half a joke.
Speaker 1: Let's say what if we had made an agreement
Speaker 1: to say, andrew, I'm not going to talk to
Speaker 1: you unless you're coming from your
Speaker 1: authentic self.
Speaker 1: I'm not even going to talk to you if you're
Speaker 1: coming from your positive ego?
Speaker 1: I said, whoa, that's pretty strong stuff.
Speaker 1: And then you'd say to me and said you also
Speaker 1: don't speak to me unless I'm coming from an
Speaker 1: authentic self.
Speaker 1: That would make for a very dynamic
Speaker 1: relationship.
Speaker 1: It might not be the kind of thing we want
Speaker 1: to do all the time.
Speaker 1: But if we would narrow down our focus in
Speaker 1: that way, it could yield some very profound,
Speaker 1: extremely transformative results.
Speaker 1: And to the ego it sounds like a terrible,
Speaker 1: an overwhelming degree of renunciation.
Speaker 1: You say, wow, yeah, but it's all good.